Speaker 1: Hey, this is really funny.
Sean HANNITY last night on his Fox News propaganda
program scrolled the list of Trump's crimes
and misdeeds on the screen.
Thinking that it's a great defense of Trump.
Thinking it's some kind of a exculpation of
Trump's misdeeds, and it makes Trump look
guiltier than ever.
You just have to see this video.
Sean HANNITY is a big Trump propagandist,
and even though as January 6th riots were
unfolding, we know now HANNITY was texting
and saying, he's got this, we've got to stop
this.
He's got to go out and put a stop to this.
This is really, really bad.
He has become a default apologist for everything
that Donald Trump has done.
And one of the stories that Sean HANNITY loves
to tell is that all these investigations of
Trump were very much unfair.
And he quite literally scrawls the investigations
on the screen last night.
And it actually reminded me that Trump has
been involved in way more wrongdoing than
I even had present in my mind, because there's
been so much of it.
Take a look at this.
This is just unbelievable.
There is.
Speaker 2: Witch hunt.
The Emoluments Clause investigation from the
House Oversight Committee, House Ways and
Means investigation into Trump's taxes.
Another House investigation into Trump's hotel
lease, another House investigation into foreign
gift disclosures.
A D.C. probe into Trump's inauguration fund
raising another similar investigation from
the Southern District of New York and the
Eastern District of New York.
And from New Jersey's attorney general.
One impeachment investigation into a regular
phone call with Ukraine.
A second impeachment investigation.
Speaker 1: And by the way, just one little
detail.
I hate to interrupt this.
I like how HANNITY calls it a regular phone
call with Ukraine.
Trump calls it a perfect phone call that would
have been a bit too much even for HANNITY.
That would have made HANNITY blush.
So HANNITY goes with a regular phone call.
While watching this, I found myself thinking,
like, as as the scroll went up and down the
screen.
As you can see here, I find myself they.
Oh, yeah.
Oh that's right.
That other oh I completely forgot about this
one.
Well that on that one he's obviously guilty
on that one.
HANNITY thinks this is some kind of defense
of Trump.
And what is basically being said when HANNITY
scrolls this indignantly is why can't they
just let him do whatever the hell that he
wants to do, whether it's criminal, whether
it's moral, whether it's ethical?
Let him do it in peace.
Anything short of that is a complete and total
witch hunt.
And it's, quite frankly, convenient for HANNITY
to put all of this stuff in one place for
us.
This is not the defense of Trump that I think
Sean HANNITY wanted it to be.
And it's a really useful clearinghouse for
us to remember all of the incredible things
that he has done.
For frame of reference.
One of these things, if it were Obama would
have been an incredible scandal on Fox News
that they would not have let Obama live down.
Speaker 2: Obama.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
And of course, there's dozens and dozens of
these, if you want to if you're just listening
today and you want to see this incredible
scroll of Trump's misdeeds from Fox will have
the clip up on our Instagram, which you can
find at David Pakman show.